hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
at the end of part three of his treatise
on the basis of morality arthur
schopenhauer has a chapter number 20 on
the ethical differences of characters
and he says that he's going to begin
with a fundamental question which is
going to complete this study of his and
he says on what rests the great
difference in the moral behavior
of human beings why do some people
act
ethically morally you know
for the benefit of others trying to
alleviate or prevent harm to them
and why do other people act differently
is it
up to all of us to choose what we're
going to do so that we be therefore
we become responsible for the actions as
well as perhaps even the character that
we develop and he's going to frame this
in terms of a couple sub questions that
fill this out
so the first one is all right he's been
developing this
uh discussion of
one fundamentally moral incentive or
motive compassion mitt lied in german
why doesn't that sufficiently motivate
all of us to
do the right things he says if
compassion is the fundamental incentive
of all genuine that is disinterested
justice and loving kindness
why is it that one man is influenced by
it and another is not
so that's a really key question and you
know this goes to the heart of ethics a
lot of times people will say oh well we
just have to teach ethics and then
people will behave well
and we know that's not the case in fact
we know people who teach ethics who are
complete scumbags you know exploiters of
their graduate students and you know
work-wise
sexual harassers sex pests of different
sorts and we can go on and on and on
right
so
if compassion is
you know available to all of us why
aren't we
all acting on its basis
and then this raises another question
okay so you know some people are
motivated by compassion other people
aren't can we take those people who
aren't and somehow bring them over to
the
other side in some way so he says
is it possible that ethics in
discovering the moral incentive is also
capable of setting it in motion can
ethics
transform the man who is hard hearted
into one who is compassionate and
thereby
just and humane so this is a great
question
and schopenhauer's answer to this is not
just no
certainly not
why not this is rather
surprising isn't it the difference in
characters he says is innate
and inerraticable so innate means it's
born within us
it's born with us you could say
and erratic in radicable means it cannot
be done away with you cannot
destroy it you cannot fundamentally
change it
so a person who's hard-hearted you're
never going to make them
not hard-hearted except perhaps in their
actions
but you're never going to change their
fundamental motivational structure
and he says the wicked man is born with
his wickedness as much as the serpent is
with its poisonous fangs and glands and
he is little able to change his
character as the serpent its fangs then
he brings up a whole bunch of
testimonies to say that bad people can't
be made good so he brings up plato's
meno quoting a passage from theogonist
theogonist indeed by instruction a bad
man is never
made good and then in the meno he says
me virtue does not come to us naturally
nor can it be taught but whoever is
endowed with it has it apportioned to
him by divine ordinance and without
intellect now of course is that plato's
actual position no i mean just read the
republic right and we see that it is
possible to teach virtue and to talk
about virtue and to explain it it's even
discussed in in the fader as well but
schopenhauer is being a little selective
in his sources uh he brings up aristotle
as well and it's very interesting that
the two texts that he brings up are not
the nick of mccain ethics and the
udamian ethics but rather the magnum
moralia and on virtues and vices which
you know
in our time most aristotle scholars
consider to be spurious works not by
aristotle but at least aristotelian
he talks about um the pythagorean
architus and he brings up uh stobayus
and and you know what he is preserved
and the basic idea here is that
everybody is telling us that no you
can't really change a person's character
he even brings up georg lichtenberg who
is a writer
you know a little bit before
schopenhauer
and lichtenberg says all virtue arising
from premeditation is not worth much
feeling or habit is the thing and
feeling or or habit habit seems to imply
that we could change our characters
and virtue from pre-meditation you know
choosing to be a certain way choosing to
behave a certain way thoughtfully
lichtenberg is kind of down on that and
then schopenhauer goes on and he brings
up emanuel kant and you know
schopenhauer does take himself to be
like the conscience par excellence and
he says
kant uh cleared up this important point
through this great doctrine that
intelligible character underlies
empirical the latter as a phenomenon
appearing in time as a plurality of
action so the empirical
actions are what we get to see they
occur in time but behind them is an
intelligible character which we cannot
directly experience but we can
make sense of through understanding
and he tells us only in this way can we
explain the rigid
unalterabilities of characters that is
so astonishing but also familiar to
anyone of experience ethical writers who
promise to produce a system of ethics
that will morally improve man and who
speak of progress and virtue are always
triumphantly refuted by
reality and experience which
demonstrated that virtue is inborn and
cannot result from
sermons so it's something original
unchangeable impervious to all
improvement by means of a rectification
of knowledge
and he brings up a very interesting
point here he says if this were not so
and if we could improve people's
character through morality um and and a
constant advance of the good were
possible the older half of humanity
would inevitably be considerably better
at any rate on the average than the
younger unless the many religious
institutions and attempts at moralizing
were to have failed in their
purpose then he says there's so little
trace of such an improvement that we
hope for something good rather from the
young rather than the old the old having
become worse through experience so you
know what we see empirically is that
people just are the way they are and
then we trace this back to their
intelligible character the thing behind
the appearances and that's
what we ascribe to them now he goes on
and he talks about the
three fundamental ethical incentives
that by this point in the work we're now
very familiar with egoism
malice and compassion and he says that
these are in all of us so we all by
human nature
have these incentives
but
we're not all the same in that respect
there's different as he says proportions
and these different proportions are
incredibly
unequal he says
and then he goes on and says in
accordance with these
motives will operate on a human being
and actions will ensue so the uh mix of
these
these different
fundamental motives is our intelligible
character the proportions of them and
then that leads to the empirical motives
within us that we might even describe
and then to
actions or lacks of actions emissions
and so each person gets a different
mixture of these it could be that some
people have the same proportions right
and how do you see what the proportions
are
well it's going to show inevitably
and necessarily
in their behavior so he says
over an egotistical character and what's
an egotistical character somebody who's
fundamentally driven has a greater
proportion of them the incentive of
egoism
only egoistical motives will have any
influence and those appealing to
compassion
or to malice will make no headway
such a man will as little sacrifice his
interest to vengeance on his enemy as to
assistance to his friend he's just going
to be egoistic another man
very susceptible to malicious motives
will often not shrink from great harm to
himself
in order to injure others for their
characters who in causing suffering to
others find a pleasure that outweighs
their own equally great
suffering and he says in fact experience
is often shown they'll deliberately
murder the man who has done them an
injury and will then to escape
punishment at once commit suicide so
egoism mouths what about compassion he
says on the other hand goodness of heart
consists in a deeply felt universal
compassion for every living thing but
primarily
for man for susceptibility to suffering
keeps pace with enhancement of
intelligence so the smarter the the
creature is the more it can suffer human
beings are the most intelligent
therefore they can suffer the most so we
need to pay attention to them and he
says that
goodness of character will first refrain
from doing any injury
um and any you know
a person is going to be
driven by this if they have that
compassion and it gives you some pretty
startling examples here
and so he says in consequence of this
incredibly great inborn and original
difference
everyone will be powerfully stirred by
those motives to which he is
predominantly susceptible
the motives of loving kindness which are
for the good character such powerful
incentives can as such have
no influence
on a man who is susceptible only to
egotistical motives so
some people are going to be
compassionate and driven by compassion
others malice or egoism
and as such there's not much we can do
about that because we can't really
change as he's going to say the heart
when we think about can we make people
more susceptible to the motive of
compassion which you know
why doesn't he ask that about malice or
egoism people are already egoistic
enough
and we don't want to make people more
malicious but we we would like to make
them more compassionate it would be a
better world wouldn't it if we could
and schopenhauer says
you can't
you can't take a malicious person or an
egoistic person
and get them to be compassionate towards
others in any real sense you can get
them to do actions that are in line with
justice or loving kindness you know
benevolence philanthropy but you're
never going to get them to want to do
that
for its own sake you can work on
means but as he's going to put it the
ends are already determined what are the
ends compassion
helping other people
preventing harm
injury
alleviating suffering those sorts of
things egoism self-interest
malice hurting other people causing them
distress or pain or things like that
those are the fundamental ends and you
can tinker around
with the structure of motivations by
approaching their as he's going to make
this distinction work on the head
but we can't actually
change
the heart and he's going to say this at
a couple different points right
when we educate people with an ethical
system or moral education he says that
the head becomes clear
the heart remains unreformed the
fundamental element the positive factor
is that which is inborn art can
everywhere only help and presumably you
could actually help people be
more adequately compassionate they want
to be compassionate we
steer them by means of you know
affecting the head into better forms of
that
we can't do much with an egoistic person
other than appeal to their egoistic
incentives so we can show them that the
ways in which they're going about things
are actually
counterproductive for them but we can't
make them care about other people for
the sake of other people we can appeal
to
a more rational way of doing this and
it's interesting because he talks about
the american
penitential
system in
this as well the american penitentiary
system the intention is not to improve
the heart of the criminal but to put his
head
on the right lines so he will come to
see that work and honesty are a sure
indeed easier way to his own prosperity
than our rotary and navery committing
crimes right
and uh he'll he'll also say this about
the malicious people we can show that
their actions cause suffering to them
this
you might actually say well wait a
second schopenhauer you just said that a
truly malicious person
doesn't care about what happens to
themselves they will
accept their own suffering they will
accept death so long as they can make
other people suffer so
maybe we actually can't do that much
with somebody who is very malicious but
maybe if they're a mixture of egoistic
and malicious we could steer the egoist
side and get them to stop hurting people
right
and he's he's going to say here
legality can be enforced through motives
not morality we can remodel
what we do
but not really what we will to do to
which alone moral worth attaches we
cannot change the goal which the will
aspires to which are these three
fundamental incentives in whatever
proportion
but we can change the path that follows
their instruction can alter the choice
of means
but not that of the ultimate general
aims every will determines these for
itself
in accordance with its original nature
so
you know we're kind of driven
by
the
character that we have this proportion
of these motives and you could say as
schopenhauer considers does that mean
that moral responsibility goes out the
window should we say well you know that
person's just a vicious bastard
they can't help being that way
and you know they're doing vicious
bastard actions malicious actions cruel
actions envious actions but that's
because they're fundamentally driven by
this proportion of malice in their
character which they were born with and
there's nothing they can do about and
schopenhauer says um no that's besides
the point what it is that we praise or
blame
is exactly the character even though
somebody doesn't have a choice in the
kind of character that they have
some people's characters are good and
some people characters are
bad
and we can call them good or bad even
though there's not an awful lot that we
can do about it other than try to
minimize the harm that egoistic and
malicious people are going to do by
showing them that it's really not to
their advantage to do that and that's as
far as we can
get with it so this is schopenhauer's
doctrine on characters and what they
have to do with morality
you